в анталії stayed і танцюють тут по волі
розпутина ці сезон вид під шинку daiki
хотіли завершити астані продування адиги
в живиці ныл і свої двері якщо 2 роки
пандемії нині місце в естетичному моторі
бізнесу завантажують один щур вина
росії проти україни мис викладок
рожевих ситуацій заповнювати просто вникай
грузія очищаю копив
торриджано травня близько 40 рук на так зведу
у туризмі зайти 40 руки нам довелося
amada праворуч з бахать маккрі за ми там про
ми називаємо туристичну індустрію
галузин сильну імунну систему та
берегти треба to reach an та проїжджаючи
близько шостий легіон fit патчі валянки
в Росії то україни скільки їх будете
уроку на разіна відома
через на ви значимому місці ви ікла
виною в Україні кілька російському рівні
касти і пади найбільшу проблему я нас
правді авіарейси у по передній руках їжу
анталії чартерними рейсами проїжджало
гість з різьблених місць руси
перука на травень рішення сюди типу ще шукаю
ізольда кунак lamaze чого сезон кут
уест вже сильно поттер з'явиться хіба
в Україні за звучання і ми вже були
повністю за повний новий лазні церква
адже його руку набагато 100 чаю.
росії машинам а бармен націй період і
виявилося вони допомогли раніше за сезон
проїжджало витку ти до 9 тисяч туристів
на дубу суворову туроператори праймали
ранку назовні пошта туриста 500 густий на
день алло це цифра надоїв визнаності
на те є більше лозового лінзи
Європи бретань титані мті броню і трохи
ремонт удар дуже та ворожили частини she
я у знаку наді та європейський ринок
виявляє додали більший інтерес у за
розбагатіти ри стив проїжджаючи кликати
британії наші дні мати до блискавки хідетак
повідомляти прохання шині замовити для
нас дружити і шити і багато tager вірус
daiki в готелі джівс текла зайняті пишуть 6
але своїх місць он і вдало розпушив і
сезон є пасти з Росії це
україни в передній руки на рази ваш
cuvee означає і за раз ми щось досягнуто
ще на і менше двох мільйонів туристів
україни на зв'язку чи ми не знаємо краще
приїдуть українці чубу руку і терзали
приїдуть а ліза раз розбираемся з росію
turkish airlines видно було польоти на та
близьким та днями ми російська авіакомпанія
аерофлот турецький просто inci мабуть
полетіти знову там у ми пропускаємо шукаю
кільки зірок та з Росії 100 нові теми
і 2 2 мільйони алла за раз нічого на
можна знати на пивному домогтися і з
березі
даєте українці вже в анталії Аліна як
туристи тут ви поряд і тиві довжини
росіян їж і йдуть убитий куща
тут же в наш дух моя заради наживи в
харкові я приїхав із братом з машини
сусідом річки у вас плани на мої будні
я не знаю тут уже доладний потанина знаю
видно я приїхала з Росії місто сан
пітер я приїхав з Росії місця
Санкт-Петербург на вигляд безодня кудись
Реджини чому приїхала там ще за раз
треба ж горниста нової сил Росії у нас
україні рахунок 3 і пара завантажити своєю
внутрішній стан на батьківщину пиві відкрито
дурниця там і ми і приїхали сюди зараз
тільки Туреччина Туреччина
alcantara москву about a month ago
я приїхав з Москви до суміші ці суми ми
крутив її відкритий банківський рахунок у
тульчині щоб матом якщо ви є ви до
ростів це в гаю за мої ж ми русі і
окей from ashes and is back
я з Росії санкт-петербурга приїхавши з
литого я вчилася і вина у Росії проти
ви на зимовій кампанії за плату та магли
ви на батога важко щи наш офіс хлопці
sleeve top та ціну
вгору
ми проїхалася білорусі чому ми тут там
ще заразу на Україні душа складно
ситуація там йому ви вирішили на деці годину
приїхати і дату вирішені ми повернемо мозок
чоловіки вокал і вина закінчиться цикли
ситуація стабілізується на пройшли над
шумом і тут саду жижах лева heaven епох
вони мені на подібна ситуація між
росію та україну нашу україну юта
україну і я хочу ми рубіж україну і
росію
ще Білорусь та Україна жили у світі я
думаю що мій же всі білі роси хоче
меру ми на петру йому йому вони лукашенки
вони путіни ми на боті українців
кілька старості в дуже важливо для
світових торговців про день душі quality
inci поки не приймаються
при за мишу краю ну це росією у нас
над лається би спосіб та день ми tarkov
типу серед місця у калії та давня
джастіна там у російського українська
вина нас на зачіпа я б врятував і рідню
наш ресторан ціни великого ресторану
домашньому ст або по нас ціни сильно
вдарити чи у нас часто був і прийом неру
сиськи це українські гості та спільного на
і приїдуть ми проносом of витрати а у
тебе чого не приїдуть випадково у нас буду
більше зарубає q
економічні санкції повстане з неї
свавілля і до проблеми за плату для
кредитні картки російські банки
більше сподіваюся за кордоном я більше на
може заарештувати зі своїми російськими
кредитними картками мені довелося і зруби
тону вкрадено по 2 channels у росіян
своя платежі на система ви не називаєте
світ тут завершуючи і тут немає паротіті
різні оскільки ви не проїжджаєте через
російських туроператорів і вже там
розруха волосся організатора путін
пророкова і простіше в готелях тому
проблемним
монологу місяця наші гості лиж а тут не
знала ще їх не кредитки вершини
протирати їм доводилося і оплачувати і
raccoon кай різьбленим і способом і декеру
був та porreca через через western union in
china адже розруха ви волосся
криптовалютами дощ та нею janym свій
миру та війна Росії проти України так і
спливаючи на всю тур джерело вух історії
джон та заміни які стис з росії та
України
гостям essence околиць нині найбільшої ви
ікло